ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้สวัสดีครับน้องเรียม
สวัสดีครับนักเรียนนวางทุกคนมาเรียนกัน
มาเรียนกันมาเรียนกันนะเกมภาษาไทยกับ
เรียมกับหน้านะคะได้ครับ ka วันนี้เรา
มาเรียนกันวันอะไรครับวันนี้
วันนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะวันนี้วันจันทร์วัน
จันทร์วันจันทร์วันจันทร์วันจันทร์อยู่
นี่วันจันทร์เราใข้นี้วันจันทร์ครับวัน
จันทร์ที่เท่าไหร่ครับวันนี้วันจันทร์ที่
20 ค่ะ
วันจันทร์ที่ 20  K วันจันทร์ที่ 25 วัน
นี้วันจันทร์เมื่อวานเมื่อวานวันอะไรครับ
เมื่อวานวันอาทิตย์เลยค่ะอ๋ออ๋อเมื่อวาน
วันอาทิตย์น้าใช้ครับเมื่อวานวันอาทิตย์
วันอาทิตย์เมื่อวานอ่ะเมื่อวานวันที่เท่า
ไหร่ครับเมื่อวานเมื่อวานวันที่เขา
9 ค่ะอ๋ออ๋อเมื่อวานวันที่ 19 เข้แล้ว
วันนี้วันที่ 20 ใช่ไหมวันนี้วันที่ 20
แล้วพรุ่งนี้พรุ่งนี้วันที่เท่าไหร่ครับ
พรุ่งนี้วันที่
21 ค่ะอ๋ออ๋อพรุ่งนี้วันที่ 21
โอเควันนี้วันนี้วันจันทร์อ่ะแล้วพรุ่ง
นี้พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรครับพรุ่งนี้วันอังคาร
ค่ะอ้าวพรุ่งนี้วันอังคารโอเคครับแล้ว
เดือนนี้ครับคนเดือนนี้เดือนอะไรครับ
เดือนนี้เดือนธันวาคมอ่าเดือนธันวาคมได้
ไหมอ่ะเดือนธันวาคมเดือนนี้แล้วปีคศอะไร
ครับปีคศ
2000  21 ค่ะอ๋ออ๋อขอสส 2021 โอเคแล้วปี
พตอะไรครับพ.ศ
2506  14
เย้พ.ศ
2506  14 โอเคครับเออเราก็อ้าวแล้วตอน
นี้ครับตอนนี้พรนี้กี่โมงแล้วครับกี่โมง
แล้วครับตอนนี้เดี๋ยวเรียมดูนาฬิกา
ครับตอนนี้ 6 โมง 55 น
[เพลง]
18:55 น
เนื้อหาเป็นตอนเช้าใช่ไหมครับอ่ะห้าหกโมง
เช้าโอเค
18:55 นหน้าวันนี้เรามี
อะไรมาสอนนักเรียนครับวันนี้วันนี้
เครียดอี้บอกว่ามีเกมให้เรียมเล่นอ๋ออ๋อ
จะให้พี่อาร์ตี้มีเกมมีเกมแก้มเกี่ยวกับ
เกี่ยวกับ
สัตว์กวางฟ้ารุ่ง
เกรียนนักเรียนรู้จักรู้จักสัตว์
ตัวไหนบ้างครับพวกนี้รู้จักบ้างไหมครับ
น้าเดี๋ยวให้น้องเรียมให้น้องเรียมบอกบอก
นักเรียนว่าสัตว์ชื่อสัตว์อะไรนะครับน้า
และก็
เอาตัวตัวไหนก่อนครับ 5 ตัวแรกตัวนี้ครับ
นี่ตัวนี้
ตัวอะไรครับ
ตัวอะไร
ม้า
อ่าอ๋อม้า
หมาใช่ไหมครับหมาหมามีเครียดฮ่าๆ
ๆหมาร้องทีครับ
อ้าวหมาๆ
อ้าเราขี่ม้าม้าจะวิ่งมาวิ่งเร็วใช้ครับ
กับๆๆๆๆๆ
k5 ตัวแรกตัวแรกมาม้าแต่น้าโอเคมีม้า
แล้วอ่าตัวต่อไปตัวต่อไป 2 วันที่ 2 ใช่
ไหมครับตัวไหนครับ
ตัวนี้ฟ้ามาอยู่ข้างๆนะโอเคอยู่ข้างๆมา
ครับตัวนี้ตัวอะไรครับเรียนนี่เห็นสีชมพู
อ่ะหมูหมู
ตัวสีชมพูโอเคชมพูเหมือนเสื้อพี่อาร์ตี้
เลยอ๋ออ๋อใช่เสื้อพี่อาร์ตี้ก็สีชมพูนะ
ครับ 5 มีหมูหมูหมู
มีหาง
หางหางหมูเป็นแบบนี้
หาใช่ไหมครับเป็นกลมกลมๆโค้งโค้งเนี่ยนะ
หาง ka  5 ตัวนี้เรียกหมู
หมูเห้อะตัวต่อไปครับ
เอาโทรศัพท์ไปตัวนี้ครับตัวที่ 3  5 ตัว
ที่ 3 ครับตัวนี้เรียกอะไรครับ
กลัวอ๋อตัวนี้เรียกวัว
เย้
เฮียตี้ถามก่อนถามก่อนวัวร้องยังไงเขา
ร้องงอขอๆโอเคน้องเรียมร้องมองเหมือนวัว
ไหมครับนักเรียนเหมือนไหม
ถ้าโอเคอ่ะตอนนี้ตอนนี้ครับ
ด้านบนด้านบนตรงนี้ด้านพญาทิพย์เปลี่ยนสี
ให้เป็นสีแดงอ้าด้านบนตรงนี้ทั้งหมด
We  Are เราเรียกเอาเรียกแถว
แถวมีแถวอาเป็นแถวแถวแถวที่ 1
หรือแถวบนแถวโบว์ในอยู่ข้างบนอีกแถวบนอา
ส่วนอันนี้ตรงนี้เราเรียกแถวเหมือนกันแถว
แต่เป็นแถวไหนครับแถวล่างแถวล่างอ่ะแถว
ล่างน่ะส่วนอันนี้อันนี้แถวบนโอเค
นามิแถวล่างแถวบนแล้วก็
ตัวนี้ครับ
อยู่ด้านไหนครับด้าน
ซ้ายหลายๆหรือด้านขวาเนี่ยนะพี่อาร์ตี้
กำลังงงสิมือนี่มือขวาต่อเนื่องขวาขวา
ฉะนั้นเพราะฉะนั้นตัวตัวนี้ชัวร์นี้ตัว
นี้ถึงที่อยู่ด้านขวาตัวนี้อยู่ด้านขวานะ
แม่ตัวนี้อยู่ด้านไหนครับซ้ายด้านซ้าย
โอเค
แล้วหมูหมูตัวนี้อยู่ด้านไหนครับ
อยู่ตรงกลางอ๋ออยู่ข้างๆโอเคอยู่ตรง plang
โอเคม้าอยู่ด้านด้านไหนครับด้านซ้ายได้
นั้นขวาขวาโอเคอ่ามาอยู่ด้านขวานะ
วัวอยู่ด้านไหนครับที่ร้านสายด้านซ้าย
โอเคหมูอยู่ตรงไหนครับอยู่ตรงกลางโอเคหมู
อยู่ตรงกลางอ่ะขอไปต่อครับ
ตัวต่อไปตัวต่อไป
นี้อยู่ครับแถวล่างใช่ไหมแถวล่างแถวล่าง
โอเค
ตัวที่ 4 อ่ะโอเคครับตัวที่ติแถวล่างแถว
ล่างด้านไหนครับแถวล่างด้านขวา
ถูกต้องครับแถวล่างด้านขวาตัวนี้ครับอ่ะ
ตัวอะไรครับ
ไก่ไก่โอเคไก่ครับเราก็ก็อ้าแล้วตัวต่อไป
ครับตัวที่อยู่หัวที่ 5  5 ตัวที่ 5
อยู่ตรงๆใช่ไหมต้องป่า
แถวล่างตัวนี้เรียกอะไรครับ
เป็ดเป็ดโอเคอ่าเป็ดน่ะตัวนี้เป็ดแล้วตัว
ต่อไปครับตัวที่ 6 แต่ตอนนี้อยู่
ด้านขวาหรือซ้ายครับตัดตัวที่ 6 อยู่ด้าน
ซ้าย
อยู่ด้านซ้ายโอเคโอเคอ่านักเรียนจำได้
แล้วใช่ไหมครับนักเรียนตัวนี้ม้าวันนี้
หมู
ตุ้ยวัวตัวนี้แม่ไก่น่าเป็นไก่แม่ไก่ตัว
นี้เป็นเป็ดอ่ะตัวนี้เป็นพ่อไก่คอไก่ได้
ครับโอเคโอเคเดี๋ยวเราจะไปเล่นเกมส์ค้นหา
ค้นหาเงาเงาขาได้ครับหาเงาของ
สัตว์พวกนี้นะอ่าเงาเงาเงาอารุงเรียนรู้
จักเงาไหมครับอ่านี่เงาไป R ที่มีแสงแดด
นี่มีพระ The  heat
ส่องแสงออกมา
ก็จะมีเงามีครับอ๋ออันนี้เรียกเงาอ๊อด
เตรียมก็มีเงาค่ะอ่าใช่ครับมีเงาอะเวลามี
แสงส่องมาก็จะมีเราหน้ามีเงาอ้าเราจะเรา
จะเล่นเกมหาเหงา
เงาของเงาของสัตว์พวกนี้เหง้าของม้าเงา
ของเป็ปน้าเจพร้อม X  R พร้อมไหมครับนัก
เรียนพร้อมไหมคะอ๋อเมตรครับมาโอเคอ่ะ
หอมแล้วเกอานี่ครับอ่ะมีอยู่ทั้งหมด
4 แถวอันนี้เป็นแถวที่ 1
แถวที่ 2
แถวที่
135 แถวที่ 4
โอเคพี่อาร์ตี้จะให้น้องเรียมหาเปิดเปิด
ได้ 2
202 ภาพใน 2 รูปสี่เหลี่ยมในเปิดได้ 2
รูปนะครับเออตาก Hey เขียนไว้หน่อย
ได้ไหมคะว่าเป็นอ่าอ่าซ้ายหรือขวา
อ๋อๆๆอ๋อ
โอเคเดี๋ยวนะพี่เขียนได้ไหมอ่ะต้องนี้
เป็นเอ่อซ้ายซ้ายก็จะเป็นใช่ไหมค่ะอันนี้
เป็น
เดี๋ยวข้างนี้ต้องเป็นขวาใช่ไหมช้าทางนี้
เป็นซ้ายโอเคเก็บไว้แบบนี้ได้ไหมได้ค่ะ
ได้เดี๋ยวถ้าพี่เอาตีเปิดแล้วมันจะหายไป
โอเคถ้าเขียนไว้ตรงนี้ไม่เห็นเขียนไว้ตรง
นี้ด้วยแชร์ OK เนื้อหาขวาหรือซ้ายมากหา
น้องเรียมเลือกครับเลือกจะเปิดจะเปิดตรง
ไหนครับบอกพี่อาร์ตี้มา
เตรียมเลือกแถวที่ 1 แถวที่ 1 ครับ
ด้านขวาหรือด้านซ้ายครับด้านขวาค่ะแถวที่
1 ด้านขวาอันนี้ใช่ไหมครับใช่ค่ะอ่าเปิด
แล้ว
โง่
เกียรติที่
เรียกว่านี่เป็นเงางามเงาของของอะไรครับ
หาเงาของม้าโอเคน้องเมียมหาครับหา
[เพลง]
หมาอายุอยู่ไหนครับ
อยู่ไหนหน้าเรียมเลือกหน้าเรืองแถวไหน
ครับ
ค่ะแถวที่ 4  5 แถวนี้อ่ะแถวที่ 4 ด้าน
ด้านขวาหรือด้านซ้ายหรือตรงกลางครับแถว
ที่ 4 ด้านขวาแถวที่ 4 ด้านขวาเพื่อตี้
เปิดนะเปิดโอ้โห
ครูอานี่ตัวหมาใช่ไหมครับนักเรียนมีหมา
แล้วก็มีเงาห่าเป็นเงาของมาร์กถูกต้อง
ครับว้าวเก่งโอเคเปิดครั้งแรกก็ถูกเลย
โอเค
หน้าต่อไปครับเรามาหาหากันต่อหน้า
เรียมเลือกแถวที่สองแถวที่สองแถวนี้แถว
นี้ครับ
ด้านซ้ายด้าน
มีหลายอันนี้ใช่ไหมครับอันนี้นะด้านซ้าย
แถวที่สองโอเคพี่อาร์ตี้เปิดน้านี้ครับ
ตัวนี้เป็นตัวอะไรครับหน้าเรียวออกมั้ย
เป็นเงาวัวเอาวัวอ๋อเพราะว่าวัวมีตรงนี้
ใช่ไหมครับนี่มีเขาใช่ไหมหาโอเคเปิดรูป
นี้แล้วเปิดรูปไหนอีกครับ
แถวที่ 3 แถวที่ 3 นี่แถวนี้โอเคตรงกลาง
ตรงกลางอันนี้ใช่ไหมครับใช่ค่ะพี่นี้จะ
เปิดแล้วนะเปิดแล้วนะเปิด
ๆฮ่าๆๆนักเรียนรอลุ้นว่าจะได้ไหมไส้ให้
วัวไหมอ่ะเปียติเปิดแล้วนะเปิดแล้วเอ่อ
ออออออออโหตว
ไม่ใช่เพียงติ๊ดผิด
หาเลือกอีกเขาเล่นเลือดอีกเอาที่ 1
แถวที่ 1 ครับฮินาตะต้องกลางนะโอเคเพียง
ตี้เปิดเปิดเกตเปิดแล้วครับอ้านิดตัวอะไร
ครับจำได้ไหมตัวอะไรไก่อ้าแม่ไก่ใช่มั้ย
หน้าแม่ไก่อ่ะโอเคอะเปิดตัวไหนครับ
เปิดอาแถวที่ 1
สาวที่ 1 ฮ้ายมือรูปนี้นะฮะเฮียตี้เปิด
แล้วนะเปิดแล้วอ่ะเปิดแถวที่ 1 สายมือแก้
เปิดแล้วว่าถ้าฟอร์ด
ไม่ใช่ถ้าไม่ใส่เพียงติ๊บอิกปิด
โอเค
ครับเอาไปแถวที่ 1 สายมืออ้ารูปรูปนี้ใช่
ไหมครับรูปเดิมด้วยนะแถวที่ 1 สายหมื่น
สายมือโอเคซ้ายมือเพื่อตี้เปิดแล้ว
แล้วก็เปิดแล้วครับแถวที่ 3 ตรงกลางแถว
ที่ 3 แถวที่ 3 ตองกลางตรงนี้จะได้ครับไป
ค่ะไอพีอาร์จีเปิดปีที่จะเปิดแล้วนะหนึ่ง
สอง
สามแยก
ใช่ไหมครับนักเรียนดูแล้วใช่เงาเงาเป็ด
ไหมไม่ใช่ไหมไม่ใช่ข้าๆใช่ไหมครับโอเค
โอเคเป็ดหน้า 3 ตรงกลางเป็นรูปเงาเป็ดเงา
เป็ดอ่ะโอเคครับหน้าต่อไปครับแถวที่สอง
แถวที่สองแถวที่สองแถวนี้อ่าขวามือขวามือ
ตรงนี้อ่าเพียงตี้เปิดแล้ว
แถวไหนอีก
เราก็
เฮ้ย
แถวที่แถวที่แถวที่ 4 แถวที่ 4 แถวที่ 4
ซ้ายมือหน้ารูปนี้อาทิตย์จะเปิดแล้วนะ
เปิดเปิดไหมเปิด
เปิดแล้ว
ว่าอ่ะ
อามาๆมาให้ตายเอาโอเคเอาใหม่โอเคอ่านัก
เรียนมค่ะอีกต่อไปครับเอาแถวไหนครับแถว
ที่ 1 แถวที่ 1 ตรงกลางโอเคเป็นแม่ไก่
เราก็แถวที่ 4 แถวที่ 4
หายอือ
เอาแน่ใจเหรอน้องเรียมกำลังหากำลังมองหา
หาอะไรครับหาเราแม่ไก่เงาแม่ไก่นะโอเค
โอเคเกียติเปิดคู่สายมือซ้ายมือโอเคแถว
ที่ 4 เปิดนะ 1  2  3 ฮ่า
ๆๆครับแม่ไก่จะได้ไหมแม่ไก่กับเงาแม่ไก่
ถูกต้องนะครับเย้เย้
โอเคต่อไป
ฮ่าๆต่อไปครับต่อไป
หาแถวที่ 3 นาทีให้น้องเรียมรีบเลือก
อยู่แถวที่ 3 ด้วยครับ
เอาที่ 3 รูปไหนครับขวาขวามือขวามืออ่ะ
รูปนี้ขวามือ
5 ตัวอะไรครับวัววัววัว
เค
หน้าต่อไปรูปครับแถวที่ 2 ซ้ายมือ
ซ้ายมือซ้ายมือตรงนี้ซ้ายมืออาเฮียตี๋จะ
เปิดรูปแถวที่ 2 ซ้ายมือนะเปิดนะเปิดไมค์
เปิด
เปิดเร็วๆนะเพียงบอกเปิดแล้วชื่อ
อะไรโคแล้วก็แค่เปลี่ยนที่
ปัดเฮิร์ทแล้วเย้เย้
อานี่เป็นเงาเงาวัวใช่ไหมครับ
เหตุดีเป็นรูปวัวเกย์ดับๆต่อไปเอารูปไหน
อีกครับแถวที่ 3 ซ้ายมือที่สามแถวนี้ซ้าย
มือรูปนี้นะพี่เปิดก่อน
นะเล่นตัวอะไรครับตัวนี้พ่อไก่กไก่อ่ะพ่อ
ไข่ก็ตั๊กแตนแล้วฮ่าๆๆต่อไปครับเอา
กับเด็กอีเอ๊กเอ๊กหรอฮ่าๆๆโอเคกระตา
กระตากต้องเป็นแม่ไก่ทักกระต๊ากแม่ไก่ xxx
a เป็นพ่อไก่โอเค
เอารูปไหนครับนักเรียนจำได้ไหมคะอ่ะมี
เครื่องจำได้
เรา Happy  is ว่าคิดว่าอยู่แถวที่เอ่อ
เออต่อขอหน่อยแถวที่ 2 เอาที่ 2 ใช่มั้ย
อ้ะต้อง plang หรือด้านขวาครับ
ฟางหรือด้านขวาหน้าอ่อนด้านขวานะโอเคด้าน
ขวามีครับ
แยบเป๊าะไก่ใช่ไหมอ่าเป็นเงาพ่อไก่อ่ะถูก
ต้องครับอ่าเหงาข้อ Kai  ka
555 ก็เหลืออีกอ้ารูปคู่สุดท้าย 2 รูป
สุดท้ายอะเปิดรูปไหนก่อนครับเปิดแถวที่ 2
ส่งกระเป๋าที่ 2 ตรงกลางโอเคอ้าตัวอะไร
ครับรูปหมู
เจ๊หมู 5 โอเคต่อไปรูปสุดท้ายรูปสุดท้าย
นะอ่ารู้ไหมเอาหมูอยู่ถ้าเป็นเงาหมูใช่
ไหม
แยกหมูถูกต้องน้ำฮ่าๆๆ
โอเคอ้าววันนี้นักเรียนได้เรียนรู้จักนะ
สัตว์หลายตัวรู้จักสัตว์อะไรบ้างครับวัน
นี้รู้จักแม่ไก่แม่ไก่เป็ด 8 หน้าหมู
วัว
กไก่กไก่กไก่คันยังไงคะเฮียติเอกี้ xa
อ่าบ้านน้องเรียมก็มีไก่เพียงตีได้ยินได้
ยินไก่หางน้องเรียนได้ยินเอาะไก่ขันโอเค
ตัวนะตัวนี้ตัวอะไรครับม้า
หน้าม้าโอเคอ้าวันนี้ก็ได้เรียนรู้มานะ
ครับรู้จักสัตว์หลายๆตัวนะครับโอเคแล้ว
เดี๋ยวหาวันนี้เรา
หมดเวลาแล้วนะครับเดี๋ยวคราวหน้าเนี่ยไป
เจอแถวนะเปรียบในครั้งเยติมีเกมสนุกๆมา
เล่นอีกเปล่าหน้าไหมครับน้ากลับมาเจอกับ
เพียร์ตีกับน้องเรียมในช่องท้องเป็นโซโล
ไทยนะค่าาวันนี้พี่อาร์ตี้แล้วก็น้อง
เรียมลาไปก่อนครับอ่ะสวัสดีครับสวยครับ
นักเรียนสวัสดีครับนักเรียนบ๊ายบายบาย